glad thanks so much for joining us today
appreciate it yeah so curious how you
know James Franco where did you two meet
we met so I'm an NYU grad student Tish
and I think the first time I met him was
through one professor and then I heard
he was doing it a like a play
installation called collage and so I
worked he needed like people to film on
stage and so I just I just I don't know
if I play for a tour they were looking
for somebody and so I just worked there
I think it was a week and it was
actually really cool that was on stage
with a camera that was plugged into like
those big screens and so I was in agent
it's actually where I met Mina too
because Nina was the lead singer and
that play and that's having that and she
she sings in a punk band right Nina yeah
yeah
and so how did James pitch this idea for
both you and Nina to be co directors for
memoria oh I mean it came together I was
I think I think originated the way work
is because I was working with me I had
expressed like I you know the fact that
I wanted to work on Palo Alto because I
had you know read the book and I thought
it was really interesting and and James
and I told James that I wanted to work
on it and then I did in my movie like
this works on mobile homes and Nina was
in it
she had a small part in it and then when
after that after having edited the movie
and I think it was a couple of months
later and then it's actually Nina who
called me if you say like Oh Jim thought
about it like would you be down to
co-write it with me and then she sent me
the three stories and and then that's
kind of like where I came in
but maybe I mean I will know better you
should ask Nina yeah we're good I talked
because they don't know I we say oh
sorry
gonna talk to her in she don't know
better cuz she might have because I know
that when I came in she had a sort of
first assembly of the three stories so
maybe James was like do one pass I
actually don't know I really started but
I know that when I came in there was
like a really short assembly of the
adaptation of the three stories and I
kind of like the first work that I did
was me and I was to reshape it and
really kind of like structure it and to
like a feature film that was really the
idea because like I originally was there
was a segment that was one character and
then another segment there was another
character and and both me and I and I
thought that it'd be more interesting to
just see them together and just kind of
like see them involved I was there
burning up what was it about those main
characters in memoria that read you what
like what kind of characteristics that
they have that you maybe resonated with
or just you know like missin ated with
the fact that like I mean I'm from
parents these kids are from Palo Alto we
couldn't be more like apart from each
other and and you know what really made
me want to do it is because it's just
it's not about that it's like if you
have like 12 year old 13 year old 16
year old you're always kind of like you
yeah you at that age where you just kind
of try to discover who you are what you
want you know I'm really interested in
that period of time where you just shake
your emotions shake yourself into
becoming an adult or at least like a you
know a confident teenager and I think
it's really interesting and I feel like
so much of us is defined by these
specific experiences that we live I'd
said too fragile
age and that's what really resonated in
me like I could find myself or people I
knew in class in Paris in some of the
characters that were like in Palo Alto